l'hôpital soigne mais qui s'occupe de
l'hôpital question cet après-midi dans
le cortège de soignants du CHU de Tours
ils étaient entre 200 et 300 à
manifester après la crise des urgences
et la réponse du gouvernement la colère
n'est donc pas retombé Sébastien Branger
malgré une revalorisation des salaires
et des promesses d'embauche rien n'y
fait l'hôpital va mal et même de mal en
Py pour tous les mêmes revendications
aux salaires augmentation des moyens
humains et matériels en revanche pour
chaque corps de métier les conséquences
de ces manquements diffèrent ici Chloé
en fin d'étude d'orthophonie mais en
cause des salaires trop bas qui poussent
ses collègues vers le secteur libéral
ça nous impacte dans notre formation
parce qu'on peut plus aller dans les
stages en structure il y a plus personne
les postes sont désertées donc notre
formation forcément elle est impactée et
puis bah voilà au niveau des patients
derrière au niveau du suivi ils ont pas
forcément le suivi qu'il faut du côté
des services psychiatriques c'est le
manque de moyens humains qui nuit à la
prise en charge des patients et à la
sécurité des soignants dans le service
de psychiatrie on fait moins d'activités
thérapeutiques du coup on soigne moins
bien les patients notre travail c'est
créer du lien et c'est pas que les
médicaments c'est faire des activités
c'est de les emmener à droite à gauche
faire des visites à domicile et parfois
on peut pas faire tout ça et du coup on
met tout le monde en difficulté que ça
soit l'équipe et la prise en charge des
patients dans les blocs opératoires le
manque de personnel provoque parfois le
report de certaines opérations et le
patient doit patienter il y a pas le
donc bah ça fait plus de temps d'attente
et donc les choses s'aggravent le
système enfin la santé de la personne
s'aggrave elle est toujours indulgence
c'est pas la solution et en plus pour
nous soignants c'est pas comme ça qu'on
a envie de soigner les gens pour les
urgences c'est parfois la fermeture pure
et simple comme ce fut le cas à Chinon
cet été dénonce le manque de personnel
depuis le départ on n'est pas plus on
est voir moi on cherche à faire des
économies encore et
ça a mis en jeu la santé des patients et
la sécurité surtout on est à la limite
de la sécurité à des moments jeudi
prochain les soignants manifesteront de
nouveau en inter syndicale et avec les
mêmes revendications